people are worried about getting sick
and they're worried about bringing home
to their families we split up volunteers
into two groups and then we wait to see
whether anyone develops a corona virus
infection after March 13th learning
looked really different some days are
better than others we're really not
taking over as teachers I could see the
writing on the wall whatever thing that
happens is always opportunity the doors
are closed but really we're still open
hope it hits it's a whole new ballgame
almost every single week
[Music]
hello I'm Donna Friesen as we exist in
this limbo balancing the need to keep
physically distant with a yearning to
get back to normal we are united in one
thing gratitude for those on the front
lines
[Applause]
it's the closest we can come to giving
our health care heroes a standing
ovation the clapping the pot banging
this singing it started spontaneously
and spread all over the world why do we
do it because while we stay home they go
to work putting themselves at risk of
getting Kovach 19 by staying home we're
helping them the spread of the virus has
slowed in Canada the curve is flattening
and our hospitals have not been
overwhelmed with patients but they are
saving lives every day
Geoff simple takes us inside one
hospital and meets a doctor whose family
constantly confronts life-and-death
questions each time the ambulance
arrives
staff at Toronto's Humber River Hospital
hold their breath concerned not only for
their patients but for themselves people
are worried about getting sick and
they're worried about bringing home to
their families worried because over the
past six weeks they've seen firsthand
what kovat 19 can do
I've never really faced anything like
this before I see it as a very high-risk
environment but this is taking it to the
highest level we have to just assume
that every piece of equipment every
piece of furniture and every other
person has coal bed and that's home
that's what our mindset has to be day in
and day out
the ambulance arrives with another
suspected case a young man struggling to
breathe this hospital is now treating
around 60 kovat 19 patients when they
first arrive winding through a maze of
machines and masks they're greeted with
a calm voice and kind eyes my name is
dr. Tori
what's the biggest problem for you is it
your breathing dr. Susan Tori is a
hospitalist her job is to care for those
who are sick but stable which describes
most of their patients with COBIT 19 we
are seeing a fair number of cases that
come in so if an average day shift we
have maybe 14 to 16 referrals from an
emergency doctor I'd say at least you
know half of those are suspected Co vyd
this patient tested positive and was
self isolating at home before he started
having trouble breathing he was found
passed out on his apartment floor sounds
like he the patient is a pretty stoic
guy and was trying to avoid coming into
hospital as much as possible but his
family then really urged him to come and
get some help but now that he's here his
family can't see him in this pandemic
they're not allowed to visit but it's
difficult you know there's patients
going through you know a lot of very
severe illnesses and in those moments
where there's high stress you know every
family member just wants to be there
holding their hands and they can't yeah
it's so instead dr. Tori takes his hand
and keeps a close eye on his condition
she's seen how quickly COBIT 19 can take
a turn for the worse just down the hall
a 62 year old woman with koban 19 who
arrived just hours ago can barely
breathe this is quite consistent it's
actually quite scary
dr. Jamie Spiegelman says it's fast
become a familiar pattern patients
suffer
flu-like symptoms for up to ten days
before their lungs suddenly fill with
fluid so it's really a very smart virus
because it gives the virus gives itself
nine days to be able to be contagious to
other people before a person gets really
really sick and to save the really sick
doctors perform a high-risk procedure
the team is preparing to intubate to
insert a ventilator to into the
patient's airway before the cold if
someone had to be intubated you know you
know we put on a mask that we'd really
all kind of rush into the room now we
have to do things a lot differently
for their own safety they've redrawn the
PlayBook deploying extra layers of
protective gear and fewer staff inside
the room others stand watch outside in
case anything goes wrong and this time
something did the ventilator tube
wouldn't fit properly her oxygen levels
plummeted and for about 10 seconds her
heart stopped more staff and equipment
were rushed inside
[Music]
the doctors performed chest compressions
and in the end they saved her life all
you want to do is help these people but
in our patients but just watching them
desaturate so quickly and not be able to
do everything that we can all the time
to help them is it is really frustrating
and it's terrible the patient remains in
critical condition but hospital staff
have given her a fighting chance dr.
Tory is done for the day but the weight
of the pandemic follows her home to her
other job a mum to six-year-old Piper
and three-year-old Reese when the
pandemic started the family debated
whether she should live somewhere else
for a while
afraid she might bring the virus home
it's constantly on my mind just in terms
of being as careful as I can
and she also worries about bringing home
her work you have to just find a way to
try and let go of it when you come home
it's not always possible
it helps she says to talk about it with
friends and family including her dad to
them
he's grandpa who's that to the rest of
us he's John Tory the Mayor of Canada's
largest city how's grandpa doing you
must be miss nice I tell you this much I
can't do this thing where I stand on the
porch like 10 feet away from them and
talk to them but I can't give them a hug
so I'm hoping to may come as soon as
possible when we can give people out he
misses his granddaughter's and worries
about his daughter I mostly think about
her
because she's in an environment where
she's exposed to people with this virus
all the time and I worry about that
Mayor Tory says his daughter wanted to
become a doctor since she was 12 after
her mother was hospitalized with a
serious illness I'm proud of who she is
and who she is fard is much more
important she's a compassionate caring
loving individual who is applying those
personality to looking after people as a
doctor I mean you both sort of find
yourselves on the front lines of this in
different ways do you do you talk about
work with each other helpful to me in
the context that I can turn to her and
ask her a few questions about all this
kind of thing from what you hear yeah
similar to last week it's it's weirdly
quiet it's a weird feeling but it's it's
like paradoxically not busy but also
busy just because of what's going on dr.
Tory is seeing firsthand the results of
her father's lockdown a surprising
number of empty Hospital things far
fewer COBIT 19 patients than they'd
feared they're also seeing a sharp drop
in the number of other non-covalent s--
traffic to their emergency ward is down
40% some of them might be people aren't
driving as much anymore so maybe we can
explain that but other people might have
worrisome symptoms and they're just
sitting on it because they don't want to
go to the hospital because the hospital
is a place where all the kovat patients
are and so they're avoiding it and and
so that's that's that's gonna catch up
to us and perhaps it already has hi
there this elderly patient just arrived
in hospital how have you been feeling
okay she's been feeling rotten for a
couple of weeks but was reluctant to
come her test results revealed she
doesn't have kovat 19:00 but she tested
positive for acute leukemia we're gonna
make sure she's very comfortable
with the visitor restrictions dr. Tory
had to break the news to her family by
phone and the next day she died that
case weighed on me because this was a
woman who was of an advanced stage she
was 90 but she was living independently
and suddenly has this illness you spend
a lot of time trying to help you know
the patient and help the families kind
of emotionally navigating the situation
and then I have to kind of move on to
another patient after that you know
there's myself and every other frontline
provider who's come home and cried but
we're human at the ends were emotional
and it's okay
you know I'm lucky I have the support of
my family now here's a question when
you're in seeing a patient who is oh hey
Piper hi can you wake the grandpa Piper
do you want to go back to school soon do
you love going to school to see your
friends it's hard families around the
world have been forced apart by this
virus and a brave few are fighting
risking their own health to help ensure
the rest of us can be safely reunited
soon see you later alligator
okay bye baby
the whole world is waiting held hostage
by a virus so new to humans
we have no immunity to it we don't even
fully understand it
what could free us is a vaccine never
before hundreds of scientists all over
the world been focused on the same thing
at the same time creating a vaccine for
Koba 19 at every hour of every day
scientists in at least 21 countries from
the UK to Russia to China and Australia
and to Germany the United States and
here in Canada are toiling away at least
115 different teams of researchers and
though vaccine development cannot be
rushed speed is of the essence this is
an international race and Canada is in
the running there is only one way to be
certain a vaccine works test it on
humans
Eliza Granado a microbiologist is the
first to be injected with a trial
vaccine for kovat 19 in Oxford England
I'm a scientist so of course I want to
try and support science the scientific
process whenever I can and since I don't
study viruses I thought it useless these
days so I felt like this is a very easy
way for me to support the cause yeah
that's why I'm here
scientists at the Jenner Institute in
Oxford are leading the pack in what's
become an accelerated race for a safe
and effective way to inoculate the world
and allow us out of our bubbles they
hope to have 6,000 people in this human
clinical trial by the end of May well I
think everybody agrees is the only way
we're going to get out of the lock down
the social distancing and really be able
to still have people protected as they
go about their daily life vaccines
usually take years not months to produce
this is happening at warp speed it's a
different urgency here in a pandemic
setting and so we're doing our phase one
the first in humans study with this
vaccine which will take place over the
next week or so and we'll immediately
roll into the next phase of the study
rather than waiting for a prolonged
period of time for all of the the
results over may months to come out all
vaccines expose the body to an antigen
that won't cause disease but will
provoke an immune response
for many vaccine hunters the key is the
spiked protein it acts as kind of a
Trojan horse for the virus bonding to
human tissue and then unleashing live
virus molecules it in theory attaches
harmless material that looks like the
virus to the spike protein essentially
fooling the body and hopefully
stimulating an immune response one that
blocks or kills the virus as soon as
China released the genetic sequence of
the virus in January work on vaccines
began at least seven teams have reached
the first phase of human clinical trials
some using weakened or inactivated parts
of the virus some using new entirely
synthetic methods nothing is guaranteed
the pressure is on definitely from my
parents where they asked me so Nadine
did you do it today do you have a
vaccine for us keep trying
human clinical trials are now underway
in the UK the US Germany and China so
many potential vaccines it's possible
there could eventually be more than one
that works I think we're very optimistic
in our vaccines ability to be safe and
potentially effective this man lost a
close friend to kovat 19 and he
volunteered for one of two human trials
underway in the u.s. you hear everybody
say this is the new normal I don't want
this to be the new normal I want this to
be an inconvenience and then we can get
back to normal in Canada this lab at the
University of Saskatchewan is on the
fast track the vaccine and infectious
disease organization international
vaccine center or Vito inter vac was the
first in Canada to isolate the novel
coronavirus and it just got twenty three
million dollars in federal funding to
accelerate work on a vaccine we operate
one of the largest high containment
facilities in the world and that allows
us to work with viruses like a colon 19
virus dr. Gertz and his team are working
on what's called a subunit vaccine only
a very small part of the virus is
introduced into the body lowering the
chance of an adverse reaction we were
also the first lap in Canada to have an
model ferrets in this case up and
running we now also have developed a
second animal model hamsters and we are
one of the few organizations in the
world right now that actually have a
vaccine already in animal testing
testing in humans at this lab it's hoped
we'll start in the fall and then be
expanded if everything goes right
Vito could get emergency authorization
for a made in Canada vaccine as early as
late spring or early summer of 2021 that
is much faster than it normally is it
can take seven to ten years for a normal
vaccine to be developed for humans so
the 12 to 18 months that everybody is
talking about is really already a very
very fast accelerated way of doing it
researchers at at least five other
Canadian universities including Laval
are working around the clock to well
there is not that many lab in Canada
actually that are that the expertise to
that they develop vaccines and I have
this expertise dr. Denis LeClair and his
team are taking a different approach
even before this pandemic they worked
with using dead molecules from a plant
virus it's harmless to humans but still
triggers a strong immune response they
look like something dangerous but they
are not at all because they cannot
replicate and that's that's the idea
it's like a lure when you go fishing you
know you want to attract the the big
fish with this that's what we are doing
with it there is lots of collaboration
and lots of promise but it's only when
solid data from human clinical trials
emerges that we'll know if anyone has
created the magic bullet it can happen
polio is once one of the most feared
infectious diseases in the world
yearly outbreaks infecting millions
killing and crippling thousands of
children then in 1955 Jonas Salk
announced he'd come up with a vaccine
and cases of polio are now reduced by
99% the scramble now is to replicate
that with a vaccine for kovat 19 the lab
that seems closest right now is the one
in Oxford England if human trials here
are a success they say they could be
ready to administer millions of doses as
soon as this
September personally I'm very optimistic
it's going to work
optimism and lots of hard work as the
world waits for science to get our lives
back to normal with me now is dr. Steven
Jones a Canadian virologist who is a key
figure in the creation of a vaccine for
the Ebola virus developed by Canada's
national microbiology lab in Winnipeg he
is now in Saskatoon dr. Jones thanks for
joining us that optimism from the Jenner
Institute is encouraging but correct me
if I'm wrong about this human clinical
trials
I think fail far more often than they
succeed and the record for creating a
completely new vaccine is about four
years so is 12 to 18 months for a kovat
19 vaccine possible it's actually a
really good question
and I was surprised to hear that they
they feel that they they would have a
candidate ready for use in September
that would be a remarkable achievement
and you're completely right
even the target of 18 to 24 months is
extremely ambitious we're essentially
two months through that timeframe so at
best 16 months away and again that's
really ambitious four years is a very
reasonable timeframe for development of
a new vaccine vaccines have been
extremely safe and effective public
health interventions because we go to
extraordinary lengths to make sure
they're safe and efficacious before
they're put into use we are essentially
giving something to someone who is at
the moment entirely well and the last
thing we can afford is for that vaccine
to have a reaction or to make disease
worse than would otherwise be which is
why we do human clinical trials we've
made vaccines of course for other deadly
deadly diseases including Ebola which is
what you were involved with but are some
viral diseases easier to make a vaccine
for than others yes they are bola was
difficult to work with primarily because
it is so dangerous to the people who are
using it and we had to work inside the
level 4 lab and use all of the special
by safety precautions and that makes it
very difficult to use with Corona
virusis the problem is slightly
different there's a certain amount of
evidence that
coronavirus is when you're infected
actually produce quite relatively poor
and short-lived immune responses to
infection and you would normally in spec
expect the virus infection to produce
you know the best type of immunity is
the other problem with corona virus is
that during the response to both the
MERS outbreak in 2012 to 14 and in the
SARS outbreak we tried to make vaccines
and if the wrong type of antibodies are
produced then they can actually make
disease worse it's a phenomenon called
antibody enhancement and it's something
that at all costs we have to try and
avoid in the development of a vaccine to
this virus that's comforting to know I
mean I'm but on the other hand deeply
worrying is it possible there is no
vaccine for any other corona virus I
think from stars to the common cold they
don't exist so is it possible that there
might not be that it might not be
possible to create a vaccine for Kovach
19 that it's just a virus that's
resistant to vaccination yes it's
possible I mean we hope not but there's
no reason to think that it would be easy
I mean it would be absolutely awesome if
we have a vaccine in September it would
actually be incredible if we have a
vaccine after 18 months that would be
you know an outstanding outcome as well
we do have to face the possibility that
it could be four years or or never a
until we start to do this we're not
going to know how humans respond to
these vaccinations and it's important to
know that not only do they have to be
safe but they also have to induce
neutralizing antibodies antibodies which
will stop the virus from infecting cells
and a lot of the trials which are being
used now are using technologies which
are in their infancy haven't been
traditionally used to make a lot of
vaccines in the past and maybe one or
two and and so we don't know how well
they'll work if it is never if it's not
possible to create a vaccine for kovat
19 where does that leave the world if
you look at some of the protector
objections which are out right now
there's a reasonably good chance I think
it's almost certain that the there will
be another peak towards the fall it's
not clear how much the virus will
disappear over the summer normally an
influenza virus sort of drops right down
it isn't clear this virus will do that
but but we would anticipate a peak and
if we have successive phases of
increasing social distancing and
economic restrictions and then releasing
them you would anticipate that there
would be a series of potentially a
series of waves where more and more
people gradually get infected from the
virus we can hope that that will lead to
herd immunity without overwhelming the
the health system but hope isn't an
awesome strategy for dealing with a
outbreak like this so I think we do have
to believe that we can make a vaccine a
lot of very clever people are working on
it otherwise we could be in this
situation for at least two years maybe
more
still ahead great my skype room
everybody just needs a little bit of
laughter and levity these days the
Canadian woman poking fun at interviews
done from home plus it's tough to turn
on a dime but you have to it's survival
of the fittest
the Canadian companies finding a new way
to do business
and up next it is causing us already to
question what we were doing what our
schools might look like in the new
reality
[Music]
if you have school-aged children then
you're working from home you're learning
all kinds of lessons about parenting in
a pandemic and you're probably wondering
when normal school service will resume
well it's slowly happening Quebec was
the first province to announce primary
schools and daycares will begin to
reopen on May 11th though attendance
will not be mandatory we think that
anyway in six months there's no proof
that we will have a vaccine in six
months so we'll be in the same situation
as today but next door in Ontario
Premier Doug Ford says it's too soon we
got to protect our children the children
can't protect themselves they rely on us
to make a decision and no one wants to
put our children in harm's way and I'm
just not willing to chance it the
messaging is confusing there are 5.6
million elementary and secondary school
students in Canada as Michael Couture
explains they and their parents are
tired and bored and are left wondering
what is the right thing to do here's a
contemporary twist on a classic math
problem Sara Sims and David Hotel have
three kids and three laptops between
them but five people who need a digital
device to work at home so how do they
get it all done right after this we've
got an online guitar lessons that are
happening at the same time as a
scheduled meeting with one of our kids
classes so I actually don't know what
we're gonna do yet but I think we will
probably end up giving of one of our
work computers for half an hour some
schools have been able to distribute
laptops to students during the lockdown
for their homework helpful perhaps but
many parents are discovering they simply
don't have the bandwidth to do their own
job from home and be teachers especially
in certain subjects I have just flat-out
said no I'm helping with algebra or
anything to do with measuring you know
yeah parallelograms or anything that's a
challenge for Matthew Dotson Roth as he
tries to keep his students engaged I
think they're absolutely have to be an
understanding that after
13th learning looked really different
the English teacher is reaching out to
students one-on-one because it's hard to
know how they're doing when you can't
read their body language in class on a
daily basis lesson plans are being
adjusted to fit this new reality and
while there are some limitations there
are also new opportunities the National
Film Board of Canada has opened its
entire collection to teachers while the
Ripley's Aquarium in Toronto has added
webcams to underwater exhibits allowing
students to visit online and there are
other examples of companies being more
cooperative during this crisis I was
talking with another English teacher
colleague and said I really I don't have
a copy of this book but I want to get it
to students and they emailed the
publisher and said do you mind if I make
a digital copy available I know there's
copyright issues and the publisher sent
them a PDF copy by the end of the day
and said don't worry about it there's
the Bell
giving students some sense of normalcy
in these abnormal times is the key it's
forcing educators to adjust
good morning Columbia Park elementary
school like this principle in Revelstoke
BC continues to read daily announcements
over Twitter he's added Friday physical
distancing dance parties to his
repertoire to spice things up as
education experts know you've got to
meet kids where they are even if it's
kilometres away in their homes hey good
afternoon class
now the mountain biking class yes that's
an actual thing in BC is a little
different online with the teacher
describing tricks and then doing them on
camera but imagine a shop class where
the teacher is used to hovering over his
students in an engine bay instead of now
talking to them over the web working on
small engines we're certainly learning
new relevant things what's created
opportunities for students to learn on
their own time at home but it still
lacks that interaction with friends we
all expect from school like you kind of
take it for granted that you see
everybody every day so I've been missing
that social aspect of school so what
will school look like in the future well
a lot of people are looking to Denmark
which was the first European country to
reopen schools albeit under very
different circumstances one classes for
example separate separated into three
different classrooms in order to adhere
to the social distancing Quebec will
follow that blueprint when schools there
reopen may eleventh each class will be
limited to a maximum of 15 students with
lunch and recess times being staggered
to avoid crowds attendance will be
optional but still some parents are
leery
I'm not worried so much about her health
and we're worried that if the kids are
carriers that they're gonna get other
people so our family our relatives my
you know my father or grandfather I'm
more concerned about that and that
concern will remain until there is a
vaccine so is this the new reality of
schooling or is it time for a rethink it
is causing us already to quest you know
what we were doing School Superintendent
Mike hooker says one of the silver
linings in all of this is the
realization that maybe a more flexible
learning environment is actually better
for students why would you run rights
from the end of the school day straight
into another set of study as opposed to
being able to leave the building or
leave the virtual classroom go get some
exercise have a nutritious snack take a
break do some things with some friends
and then come back again and now you're
refreshed and ready for some more
learning there's no question that it's
important to return kids to schools
because of those interpersonal
interactions that shape us during our
formative years but it's possible
a hybrid education system of both online
and in-person learning will be the new
reality preparing students for a world
where working from home is the norm
for many people working from home now is
the new normal what is not normal is
what many businesses are going through
new data from Statistics Canada shows
about two-thirds of Canadian businesses
have been highly affected by lower
demand for their products and services
about half say it's so bad they've been
forced to cancel services they sell
those who survive are those who adapt
those who managed to turn lemons into
lemonade
tonight three companies share their
stories of finding new ways to do
business hi I'm Kerry silver the owner
of encore catering I've been in business
since 1979
we've catered over 40,000 meals in my
career to this point the bulk of our
business is being basically social and
corporate catering where we've done
product launches car launches weddings
bar mitzvahs christenings those types of
events I could see the writing on the
wall where events were starting to
cancel as early as March 2/10 people
were starting to cancel their events
fortunately I've got a couple of younger
sons that work with me
and decided to do a grocery home
delivery prepared food service which is
taken off at the beginning of March and
it's feeding and growing ever since
they're preparing at home they don't
want to go into the supermarket you need
tomatoes ooh sup my name is Ryan silver
and I'm the director of encore catering
we're here for the community and the
community's really been there for us and
that's the most important part to take
away from this with contactless delivery
coming into the kitchen wearing a mask
wiping down boxes every piece that you
know we don't we don't like delivery
people into the building they have to
drop it on the loading dock we have to
check it we don't sign paperwork hand
sanitizer
washing observe and you get a lot of
celery to it we do support a lot of
frontline workers through our donate a
meal program and we hear the feedback
and of what's actually happening in the
hospitals and it's scary this isn't
going away and maybe it's going away for
the short term but it's not going away
for the catering business for a while
and our businesses is change for six
months to a year for the foreseeable
future so we need to adapt so we need a
pivot and that's what we've done it's
tough to turn on a dime but you have to
it's survival of the fittest and so you
do what you have to do and you just do
it and we've done it my name is Aziz
Allah co-owner at good neighbor it's a
mini department store we call it it's
more than clothing we do or footwear we
do a lot of lifestyle anything that
relates to a young family and their kids
pre coalbed we were doing incredible
we're doing very well we were very busy
we took on a big expansion plan for the
store a second floor we didn't know the
severity of it until it hit us and we
right away figured out we have this
little website that we had pre kovat
it's a brick and mortar business it was
never gonna be an online business but
online has exposed us in a different way
now it's organic to mean a bidder all
the government support that we got thank
God we were able to hold on to some of
our staff and they were they were key in
this thing they all rallied around the
business and they helped us out to on
personally to fill the store the only
store the doors are closed but really
were still open I am I personally really
engage with these people I know them all
very well so I decided to take on the
whole delivery of the local area for
myself I started knocking the door
leaving a box running out of there with
my mask on and it turned out that
everybody everybody started coming out
of the doors and saying hello to me and
that was that was amazing it's a
lifeline right now it's only it's a like
I said it's a drop in the bucket for
what it needs to happen the most
important thing that could have happened
is because it is keeping us in engaged
with our actual consumer who shops here
good morning guys my name is Shaheed
cash Vani nickname is Shady childhood
nickname
we've been open Farris 360 for seven
years and we have 12 staff we do group
fitness we do personal training classes
here a little bit on the tougher side
but we look to cater to all levels we
would see anywhere between 350 450
people a week you can imagine March it's
a busy time for gyms we're sort of live
and things are happening and all of a
sudden colvett hits we work with all the
protocols and then eventually shut
things down I thought you know we have
to still feel like we're part of the
community and have the community feel
like there's still a part of us people
want to rent out equipment so that when
basically in two days all of our
equipment when you come straight from
there we also included live classes so
zoom classes I sort of stepped up to the
plate after feeling really down but you
know something just clicked I had a lot
of good people around me that motivated
me 20 squat rotate just the other day we
had a class live I think there's most 65
people so it was awesome we're in a
position now where
you know there's the community give back
the rent relief you know we couldn't be
happier about that it really puts us in
a position to look forward it's a whole
new ballgame almost every single week so
more than that I'm just looking for the
health of sort of everybody it's a it's
a tough time for people out there and
you know you just hope for the best for
everybody and that we come out of this
sooner than later coming up next a sign
of the times you don't know why you're
in the wrong place and you don't have
the information how the koban 19 crisis
is making a silent world even quieter
for the deaf community it's occasional
never forget crying beat from the files
of Global News and the reporters who
covered them tube stories behind some of
Canada's most high-profile homicides
Klein beat Saturday at 7:00 on global
when we're in the middle of a crisis we
look even harder for people and sources
of information we can trust all those
briefings by public health officers and
political leaders are must-see TV for
lots of Canadians who are trying to
navigate this uncertain future in Canada
they happen in English and French and in
sign language the sign language
interpreters have become increasingly
visible and popular in this crisis Mike
gelée explores what a lifeline they are
for the deaf community for every
grim-faced politician with even more
grim news a silent partner stands to the
side a lifeline to the deaf community
and especially in a time like this when
there is a crisis who's the most
vulnerable people as those people that
don't have access to information and
while the death live in silence kovat 19
has made the world even quieter with so
many people wearing masks it's near
impossible to tell when someone is
talking doing groceries with access
rules changing daily can be confusing if
not terrifying and so you go in and it's
kind of like a gamble right do I go to
the right choice line up here there's
you know somebody says something to you
because you've been in the wrong place
you don't know why you're in the wrong
place and you don't have the information
they may be talking to you but you're
not hearing what they're asking you to
do so there is anxiety that anxiety has
been all but ignored amidst all the
stories being done on interpreters
they've become a thing of headlines
lauding their personalities you've
likely heard of Nigel Howard in BC who
has become a celebrity with fan pages
and posters and a u.s. interpreter with
an uncanny resemblance to David
Letterman became clickbait Christopher G
all this was before Ontario's Doug Ford
gave interpreter Christopher Day lodge a
premier pat on the back my friend you're
a champion you're a rockstar now there's
no question Ford was being sincere but
like most hearing Abel people he played
into a stereotype that deaf community
often complains about that their
language is entertainment
our top story tonight interpreters are
expressive by design they wave their
arms and make faces it's part of their
language for some people effect is the
tone of your voice but for other people
effect is the words you choose
and while Windsor interpreter Rebecca
stuckness grew up with two deaf parents
she still defers to interpreters who are
deaf because American Sign Language or
ASL is their first language let's not
kid ourselves people are always looking
for inspirational porn
you know that's we go to the internet
for that we're always like you know
where's the feel-good story oh look it
brought tears to my eyes we all need
that we need that positivity the deaf
community needed the same thing as
everyone else information the day after
Ford's praise viewers wondered what
happened to his interpreters physical
distancing rules meant they were moved
to another room and technical challenges
mean they're available widely to the
public only via the provinces YouTube
page in Saskatchewan they didn't even
have an interpreter at all leaving the
deaf community to look elsewhere a
friend of mine she had to watch the Los
Angeles news because they had the
interpreter on the screen full-time
after a few complaints the problem was
rectified new infections are starting to
level off there are more interpreters
working now than there were a month ago
using a sign created specifically for
this pandemic my understanding the signs
of Kovach actually came from Chinese
sign language but knowing how to sign
kovat is one thing knowing you're
getting all the life-saving information
that comes with it is another entirely
coming up from the good seems like
everybody wants to be in front of a book
go to the bad sometimes the lighting
isn't good the BC woman raiding our
rooms
[Music]
part of our new reality means we can't
go to people's homes right now but we
sure are getting glimpses inside a lot
of them all the people working from home
and appearing on skype and zoomer
inadvertently giving us windows into
their worlds and it's not always
flattering a twitter account called rape
my skype room is keeping track of them
it's fearlessly reviewing the staging
behind everyone journalists celebrities
pundits politicians here's one
Gwyneth Paltrow limited bar cart bad
light try an enema three out of ten
and here's Hillary Clinton the room is
bright and the decor is charming the
view through the window is lovely 9 out
of 10 and how about Justin Trudeau
during this week's virtual Parliament
good mix of well read books photos and
object a well-placed succulent would add
color 8 out of 10 well the woman behind
all of this is Canadian Jessie berry who
lives in Port Moody DC and Jessie joins
me now Jessie so great to talk to you
does that surprise you that some people
who look so good on TV and in movies and
Studios really look kind of pretty
ordinary or or even worse at home on
skype I think that was actually part of
the reason why this has been such a big
hit is because everybody can relate to
people who have laundry have a cat
photobomb have kids run into the room
have you know photos that aren't
perfectly straight on the walls and I
think it makes it relatable I think it
makes it fun and I think everybody just
needs a little bit of laughter and
levity these days what are the key
components that you think make for a
good backdrop for a Skype interview well
the angle of the camera is really
important because a lot of times you get
too close they're too far away in that
Rex the shot
sometimes the lighting isn't good I
would say that the bright colors and
plants add a lot to the room what is all
this success this appeal that you've had
on Twitter tell you about how we're
managing to connect with viewers and and
people who
you know we don't really have a window
into their world you know when we first
started I didn't realize how people were
feeling isolated and I think that every
time you turn on the news it's obviously
all about the coronavirus how it's
changed lives you know all the negative
things I think people really glommed on
to this because it was something
different it was fun it broke up the
news cycle I also think that people are
just spending more time at home whether
they're working from home or the social
isolation and it gives people something
to talk about okay so final question how
hard did you work on your own room there
it looks beautiful got a bit of greenery
behind you the mantelpiece in a photo
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna have to tell
the truth I spent most of my weekend I
actually had quite a long weekend doing
that so I will admit that and I have new
appreciation for people because it's not
as easy as it looked not at all coming
up
Canadian kids singing their hearts out
[Music]
there's so much information surrounding
coronavirus out there now we know you
have questions email your questions at
Global News Don CA tune in to global
national or go to global MCA /
coronavirus now to find the answers
and that's our program this week we
leave you with some unvarnished
enthusiastic and super cute kids singing
their hearts out as part of the Canada
together initiative in support of
frontline workers singer kids and Anna
Tunis
[Music]
bless you